many of you probably heard the big news
about the Boy Scouts this is a big story
last week the organization decided to
allow girls to join and they officially
changed their name to just Scouts yeah
now of course of course a lot of people
have opinions about this and they're
wondering if making the organization
co-ed is a good idea we haven't talked
about it yet what do you what do you
think Andy well I don't want to sway
anyone's opinion but I did get my hands
on some footage from the co-ed scout
camp I think a lot of you'll find it
very troubling take a look
which one you did this
hi I'm Andy Richter and I'm here to talk
to you about implicit bias if you watch
that clip and assume the owner of the
curling iron would be a girl then you
just showed implicit bias okay I think
we got it let's give it up for my camera
operator Sam hi again sue my camera
operator Sam was a man you once again
shown implicit bias check your bias okay
guys we're really done now I have to
take my car to the mechanic mechanic is
a woman damn it people this is
exhausting I'm spending the rest of my
day fighting against gender inequality
[Applause]
hi i'm conan o'brien and if you really
thought Andy was gonna spend the
afternoon on activism instead of taking
his usual nap and you just showed
implicit bias
hi I'm Andy Richter and he thought Conan
wasn't going to be a great a douchebag
about this then you showed implicit bias
hi I'm Fiona Brian but if you thought
Andy wasn't gonna get way too emotional
and overreact to my teasing then you hi
I'm Andy look if you thought this sketch
was better before Conan and surgeon
himself into it then needs me hi I'm
Conan O'Brien and I'm sorry but the last
time I checked the show's called Conan
high on Conan O'Brien
you're so sensitive because you're
always undermining me and I'm here to
promote the new season of Arrested
Development available May 29th on
Netflix this whole thing
if you thought it was a colony sketch
then you've just shown implicit bias
[Applause]
I have no idea what just happened
you